chip roy great us congressman republican
congressman
former chief of staff to senator ted
cruz
chip roy is pointing out the hypocrisy
here he's had enough of this there's a
crisis at the border and yet nancy
pelosi is now making
all of these vaccinated members of the
house mask up again
we have a crisis at our border and we're
playing ftse with mask mandates
in the people's house i mean it's
absolutely absurd
what this body is doing the people's
house it's an embarrassment it's a
mockery
and the american people are fed up they
want to go back to life they want to go
back to business they want to go back to
school without their children being
forced to wear masks
to be put in the corner to have mental
health issues and we're running around
here
and the speaker comes down here at 10
o'clock in the morning saying we got to
wear masks
in the people's house while we've got
thousands of people pouring across our
border and democrats don't do a darn
thing about it
heavily infected with cobit we have the
new york times
okay today what a mess oh you got a
pause right there before
chip roy goes on and makes i think a
very important point but you got to
pause right there
because if you weren't watching marjorie
taylor green
who is this lightning rod for the left
she just walks into the frame she came
in late while chip roy was talking
completely unmasked sits down doesn't
care that's really great
so chip roy goes on and makes a point
that could get him kicked off of
facebook we have people infected with
covet coming around our southern border
into texas
and you all put masks masks
up front here here on the people's house
we got to go around and see okay we
can't come to the floor i can't execute
my constitutional duty
unless i wear a mask well which is it
vaccines or masks
do the vaccines work or they don't work
do the maths work so they don't work
i'd like to know which it is i'd like dr
fauci to come down and answer a single
question
about natural immunity have you been
infected with a
virus do you have immunity or are they
just going to go around poking people
saying you must take a vaccine oh but
sorry the vaccine doesn't work
you must wear a mask this institution is
a sham
and we should adjourn and shut this
place down amen chip now you'll notice
chip roy said something here that
according to the new facebook guidelines
could and again it'll be so arbitrary
and capricious
could get him kicked off of facebook or
get a content strike against him or
something like that
and by the way all of these politicians
have very large facebook pages because
this is the public square and that is
how they campaign what chip roy said
is or what he what he implied but
he basically said it out right is that
if they're
if the cdc is requiring us all to mask
up again and pelosi and all the rest of
them are going along with it
then it that suggests that the vaccines
do not work particularly well because
he's saying if the vaccines worked
then you wouldn't need to wear the masks
now i want to be i'm being so specific
with my language facebook pay close
attention
i am not i'm being really nice here i'm
not even dealing with the point that
chip made the very
interesting and good point the chip made
i'm dealing with
what that means what it means
that some billionaire in silicon valley
named mark zuckerberg hired a bunch of
punk
tyrants who are now going to go channel
by channel
and say no u.s representative you can't
say that
no member of congress you can't say that
forget about chip roy
they did this to trump in january no
duly elected sitting president of the
united states
you can't say that because i
either some apparatchik at facebook or
twitter or google or or one of the
surveillance tech billionaires
themselves
because they say that you can't say that
as i point out in my book which i do
think
becomes scarier and scarier every day
how true this has become speechless
if you control speech in a republic such
as ours
you control the political system because
speech is politics and politics of
speech we govern one another
by persuasion and deliberation
right now a very small number of people
who have all of your data and know
everything about you
but who have crucially never appeared on
a ballot you've never elected them
they are controlling all of your speech
including the speech of your elected
representatives including the speech
of your presidents i'm glad you liked
that clip
i need you to do me a favor i need you
to head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your podcasts
and subscribe to the michael knowles
show then leave a five star review
and stick it into the eye of big tech
sensors who are trying to tell me what i
can and cannot say
i really appreciate it subscribe like it
you know get the book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
see you next time
[Music]
you